no matter who else may be speaking
thank you sam i think we are ready to
begin
thank you so much brenda and i'll turn
to alicia
the city clerk and alicia could you
please call the roll
yes sir good evening everyone
councilmember rocket
listen friend here
joseph
nego is absent sweat
here wallet present
weaver here
here and yeah present
mayor we have a quorum thank you very
much
as i think you are all aware um we have
had a horrific
tragedy strike boulder we've lost 10
members of our community
and we are here tonight to discuss that
to heal to begin the process
of figuring out our next steps together
to hear from the community what you
think
our next steps need to be i want to take
just a moment
and acknowledge the the grief
that the families of the victims must be
feeling
um i also want to thank
the first responders who responded
monday both from
older police one of whose member paid
the ultimate price for their response
officer eric talley and thank fire
and thank all the surrounding
communities who sent first responders
to this incident they saved lives and
they helped apprehend
the suspect which is of course critical
to our sense of closure and justice
i also want to thank the rest of our
staff
the the first responders are seen and
visible
the rest of our city staff has been
working
incredibly hard both to set up for this
meeting
to get all the folks who are here
assembled and
briefed and ready to to do their part
and
many other things such as assembling the
links to be able to donate to support
the victims families
as well as links to mental health
services that we'll discuss more later
so
thank you to our staff for your
extremely dedicated service to all of us
um with that tonight we have
just the one subject and we're going to
treat it as a matters item so
we have invited speakers to speak to us
if all goes well
we will also have a staff representative
at the vigil there's a vigil that will
be starting at seven o'clock
on the boulder courthouse lawn if things
go well we'll also hear
from a few people who are at that vigil
but at the very least our staff member
chris messchuck
the acting city manager will deliver
remarks from the city to that vigil
with that i am going to turn to the
invocation we are going to set the tone
tonight of healing remembrance
and community and we're going to do that
with a joint invocation
from mary kate rouge and rabbi fred
green
so if we could start that recording
mayor pro please weaver city council
members
thank you for the opportunity to be with
you today
and to offer this invocation on the
event of
terrible violence in the boulder
community
a few days ago i have invite invited my
friend and colleague
rabbi fred greene of congregation
hashem to join me because in times of
trial we are better with the support of
friends
i encourage all who listen tonight to
seek
company and counsel if you find yourself
struggling to endure
you are not alone this invocation
uses a prayer authored by rabbi edith
mentioner
modified for this occasion we
apologize in advance for names
not pronounced correctly
we stand in grief with the devastated
families in our community
we weep over the incomprehensible loss
of life
we cry out with shock confusion and pain
we mourn together over this senseless
act
of violence and destruction
we remember persons fathers and mothers
sons and daughters friends and neighbors
husbands and wives
three of them the age of us a rabbi
and a priest four older three
younger each one known best to those in
their near orbits
each one with mysteries not yet revealed
let us now hear their names and
the smallest portion of their lives
49 years old shop manager
and organic boulderite newly engaged
full of love and light
suzanne fountain 59 years old
a gardener who shared abundance in
leaves of lettuce
an actress a medicare genius who will
not
reach the age to apply for the same
terry lyker 51 years old
a 30-year king supers employee
a kind and fierce bagger of groceries
special olympian and olympic class
friend
kevin mahoney 61 years old
a retired chief operating officer of
hospitality
and hotels and almost grandfather who
will not welcome
this grandchild
lynn murray 62
photo editor in cosmopolitan landed in
boulder
instacart driver mother artist
designer
ricky olds 25
front end manager oldest sister
hiker and camper her love of
independence did not keep her free
from being killed in her place of work
denny stone 20 an employee
dreamer an outdoorsman an aspiring pilot
whose high school graduation was just
blocks away and two years ago
23 years old a son of immigrants
already once a refugee of violence
in a war zone fixer of coffee machines
not yet old enough to rent a car
eric talley 51 an officer among our
heroes in the boulder police department
the boulder county sheriff's department
and the cu
police department beloved and loving
father
a woodworker and the first one whose
name we knew
jodie waters 65
boutique owner and every shopper's
friend
on the pearl street mall a mother and
grandmother
last in the alphabet and the oldest
among them still too young
for their beloved families and friends
we grieve be with us god in this
time of sorrow and fear
help us god to offer comfort to those
whose hearts are shattered
rekindle hope and trust and courage with
us
help us to sustain our belief in the
promise
that even in the most burdensome of
times
even when we feel most discouraged
love is never extinguished
and light and spirit will prevail
help us to rededicate ourselves to
building
a world that is safer for our children
help us to build a world that is safer
for all people
during these difficult days and nights
nights may we find comfort and
hope and light to bear the burdens of
broken hearts
and a broken world
o says
may the one who causes peace to reign in
the high heavens
and the person near us let peace
descend upon us amen
well thank you
so i think we i'm hearing an
interpretation let me double check
mine should be off so brenda can we make
sure that we've got the interpretation
on the chin
marina sorry you're in the english
channel
um so let's meet you for now and and you
and i will keep working on it
very good one more time thank you
reverend roger
and rabbi we're supplying that um
wonderful invocation to start this
terrible meeting um i want to pass along
i received a call today from u.s
president joe biden
and he expressed his deepest sympathies
to all of boulder specifically as well
to the
victims families and also called out
officer talley by name for his heroic
efforts and sacrifice
that he made um there's more to the
conversation that i had with the
president
and i will reference that when we speak
at the end of the meeting tonight but i
do want everyone in boulder
to know that we have a leader of our
country who feels the pain
that bolderites have experienced he
sympathizes
with our loss and he intends to work
with us
to try and bring change to the laws that
govern
the weapons that killed the people in
our community
with that i'm going to turn it over to
the governor of the state of colorado
jared polis to hear a few words
thank you mayor weaver it was you know
when you mentioned at the start of the
meeting
this is the agenda um of course
it's all consuming what else can can
possibly be thought of or talked about
um as you know not only do i have the
great honor to be
governor of the state of colorado but
i'm a bolder native
boulder resident and you know what
many of us knew the victims firsthand
knew people who knew them bolder at the
end of the day as a small tight-knit
community
i have several friends who lost
somebody that they cared about that they
knew well
um at the king super's killing but
whether you
knew some of the someone who personally
or not who perished
uh this was a blow to the entire
community it really
when we see these tragedies happen in
different parts of our country
everyone likes to think that wouldn't
happen here
and it happened here and it happened at
a place that
many of us have been i've shopped there
you've shopped there
uh stopped there when i'm in south
boulder to pick up food
something that we can all identify with
it could be any grocery store
could be anywhere in our state anywhere
in our country these were
10 men and women just going about their
day like you and me some of them
working some of them shopping making a
quick drip trip
to grab dinner
and on monday afternoon evil manifested
and cut their lives short there's
there's been a lot of talk in the days
and weeks ahead what could have possibly
been the motive or the motivation or why
but there is no motive or explanation
that can justify the action or they can
relieve
the pain of those left behind and our
entire community
you know grocery stores are really a hub
of our community
and we have that expectation of
familiarity
of safety and that's why for many of us
this attack feels so
personal that could be any of us at any
store
at any time and i want you to know this
tragedy is not just
touch boulder in our state but i've seen
such an outpouring of love
and support from people across the
country
and across the world for boulder
and our residents in our time of need
earlier today i stopped by king super
table mesa and saw the ad hoc memorial
and paid my respects laying down a
bouquet of flowers
along with hundreds if not thousands of
other
flowers and i was very heartened to see
so many
of our fellow boulder rights doing the
same and he brought flowers made signs
laid down special tokens some were
friends of
people that were lost and in many ways
just two days after the attack it still
doesn't feel fully real it's still hard
to
hard to understand that this happened
here
i want to encourage everyone to give
ourselves
the space to grieve the space to be
angry to be sad
to be confused to ask why questions that
can't be answered
but must be asked and nothing about what
happened monday is normal
and we must do everything that we can to
keep ourselves
and one another from becoming
desensitized to this pain
even if that seems like the easier
choice and support
it's important to own this pain
and remember what happened
we are familiar with tragedies like this
in the abstract sense we've
heard about them we've read about them
but it came to our community
and it could come to any community to
the 10 families
survivors the friends who were waking up
every day without their
mother or father son or daughter sister
brother on behalf of the state of
colorado
express our love and condolences the
entire state of colorado is with you
and the entire state of colorado stands
with boulder
as coloradans we remember denny strong
nevin stanisic ricky olds
shalonna bartowiak terry liker
eric talley suzanne fountain
kevin mahoney lynn murray
and jody waters thank you
thank you governor and i will turn next
to um senate colorado
state senate majority leader steve
fenberg
thank you mayor weaver um and
uh thank you for
for having this conversation um
this is something that we have all um
seen happen across the country
uh i think it
became all too normal right and this is
something so many different communities
have experienced
personally and then over the last
year it feels like um
as nothing was normal because of this
pandemic and our world was
turned upside down dozens of different
times in different ways
this is something we haven't actually
seen a whole lot of
uh as a country fortunately
the thing that makes me so angry is that
it feels like as we get back to normal
as we contemplate being able to go out
to a restaurant
or do the normal things that we've
always taken for granted
unfortunately that coming back to normal
includes seeing um headlines of
horrific events in the news
that's the part that makes me so angry
is that
back to normal has to include that
i think we all
[Music]
want to get back to a level of normalcy
i also think we
have an opportunity here to reset
and have a difficult conversation of
what normal is or what it should be and
what is a healthy
normal um clearly
what happened in atlanta and now what
has happened in our community is not
normal
by any stretch of the imagination at
least not to
to any other country right um so
i guess first and foremost
obviously my thoughts our thoughts
and condolences are with the the victims
and with the families and those that all
of
uh the all of us that have been touched
in one way or another by uh
them their their
their roles in our community the just
we've all been touched in one way or
another
um there's just going to be a long
road ahead of grief
for the families it's going to be an
impossibly long road
we have to be there to show up for them
we we absolutely need to
at the same time concurrently talk about
what can be done
uh to prevent something like this
happening again
and making sure that something
good comes out of this but we need to
make sure that first and foremost
our our role also is to be neighbors
to to continue uh to show love and grace
and
and and be there for the community and
for the individuals that are hurting so
much
today and into the near future
um i'm not gonna
i'm not going to get into a lot of
policy
discussion i don't think that would
necessarily be appropriate
um but i will say that i am
um i've talked to several of you over
the last couple of days
they're going to be continued
conversations about what can happen at a
state level
um obviously the the court ruling
around boulder's uh policy
is top of mind um it has to be part of
the conversation
it can't end there because we know
that's woefully inadequate
to create a safe community
so those are conversations that are
happening and
more and more so will happen um in the
forefront
uh as a community and i am welcoming
that conversation
i am eager to be a part of that
conversation
in in any and every way that um makes
sense or where i can be helpful
um uh representative mobile and
representative hooton and i just had a
town hall with
several others joining and we've we had
this conversation about what needs to
happen what can happen
what may happen at the federal level the
state level the local level
and the answer is that there's obviously
not a single solution
but but that can't keep us from
seeking solutions and making
taking those steps that will
um make our community safer so
what i guess i i'm here to say tonight
is that
um to implore that that our community
gets tighter than ever and that our
community shows up more than ever and
this is a community that does show up
um as city council members i think you
guys are well aware of that
and we need to channel that um as a
community
towards being there for our loved ones
for for our community members
so we can get out of this and build
something that is stronger more
beautiful more resilient
more safe than we've ever been
but at the same time we all need to
think about how we can make sure that
this is not a moment that is just
another one of these moments in this
country
we owe it i think to the victims um
we owe it to everyone who's touched by
it
to to not let this just be another
moment and not
let this be the return to normal
um and so at the state level
what i can assure council members and
the community at large is that we are
eager to have those conversations
they're going to be difficult they're
going to be challenging i can't say
uh with any confidence that that i know
exactly what
is going to happen but we are going to
have the conversations everything
is going to be on the table and i can
assure you that the
the delegation from the city of boulder
is
going to be in lockstep together to make
sure that we do
whatever is within our power that is the
most effective
most meaningful uh change that that we
can get done
um to make sure that
we can prevent the next tragedy from
happening including making sure that the
city of boulder has
the right to go above and beyond what
state regulations
exist or will exist after this session
but again i don't think that is the
answer there is no answer there is no
one
solution it has to be a continued
conversation that evolves
um because you never get to a place
where you can say great we passed a bill
or we passed a policy and now
they're um we have solved this problem
this is something that we have to work
on together over
time and um many would say it's too soon
to talk about any of that and i get that
and i appreciate that and i respect that
perspective
um personally and i said this on the
senate floor yesterday
it's it's obviously too late it's not a
question about is it too soon
it is too late and um we need to do
everything we can to make sure that
um this tragedy doesn't happen again and
that our communities including boulder
but every other community in colorado
um is safer uh because we can't let this
become
uh the return to normal so i'll leave it
there
um mayor weaver council members others
my door is always open to have these
conversations and to strategize and to
talk about what comes next
um but for now my my hearts are with
this community and
and i want to thank you for inviting me
and having this important conversation
thank you so much senator much
appreciated
um next we will go to um
congressman joe nagoos who is here with
us
thank you mr mayor and uh good evening
to all the council members uh mayor pro
tem joseph and and to mayor weaver and
uh
to all the folks who are listening in
here in boulder um
i wish i was here under better
circumstances to to see you all
but i'm grateful for the opportunity to
come by and say a few words
and grateful for you all holding this
special meeting
to honor the victims that our community
lost
on monday night i know i don't need to
tell
each of you how devastating
uh the events of the past few days have
been for our community
i would simply say to you that as i've
received calls from
the speaker of the house and countless
of my colleagues
in the house of representatives on both
sides of the aisle republican and
democratic members they each one
have offered their condolences to the
families who
lost loved ones on monday and have
offered their thoughts and their prayers
to
our community and i just hope you all
know
that the rest of the country is thinking
of our community
and as i've talked to my colleagues
i've tried to explain to them those who
haven't been to boulder before
that it's a small community it's a
strong community but it's a small one
it's a close-knit community and
the loss of life is unimaginable
but in particular for a community like
ours
to lose 10 fellow community members
people who were brothers and sisters
neighbors friends colleagues
family members i'd be there
to have such a tragedy unfold here in
boulder county and in the city of
boulder
uh is uh it's is
hard to describe in words i want to say
thank you
to the city of boulder to the mayor
to every one of you to your staff
to the boulder city police who are
heroes
we all of course continue to mourn
the service and the sacrifice of officer
talley
we remember him and his sacrifice his
service will never be forgotten
we mourn his passing
and i want to say thank you to chief
harold
for her strength
and the way in which she and
so many of the officers in the boulder
police department have responded
to this tragedy both during the
harrowing events of
monday afternoon and in the days since
uh we are in their dead i also want to
say thank you to the district attorney
who has done a tremendous job
as he works to pursue justice in this
case we are lucky
to have such an exceptional person
leading our district attorney's office
here in this community
certainly federal resources will be
available
our office always stands ready and able
and willing to help the city of boulder
to the extent that you all have needs as
we
respond to this tragedy i'm grateful
that so many in the community have come
together and
are supporting each other during this
difficult time so many mental health
professionals here in our community who
are helping those survivors
i also want to say uh thank you to our
local press
again when i talk about boulder county
being a small community
and the way in which this tragedy is
impacting every facet
of the city of boulder that includes the
press
that keeps us accountable and that
provides
readers and citizens across our region
with such incredible reporting and the
daily camera mitchell buyers
all the folks who have been reporting on
the terrible events in real time we're
grateful to them as we are to the
business community and i know john tears
on
as well from the chamber for their
efforts in supporting
the businesses in in south boulder
i the last time i was here in front of
the boulder city council
testifying was as a citizen not as a
member of congress
many of you were on the council at that
time
my director of community affairs who
does a tremendous job
in our office was on boulder city
council and she authored
a measure to ban assault weapons and i
testified and supported that measure
i'm grateful to her for her leadership
at that time i'm grateful to the council
for stepping up at that time and i am so
frustrated and angry
that inaction at the federal level has
compelled
cities like our own to take such steps
because
federal policy makers have been
incapable or unwilling
to do what was required of them
which was to save lives in communities
like ours
and to see what unfolded on monday
happen here in our community and to see
fellow community members lose their
lives in another terrible mass shooting
it it's again difficult to comprehend
and so frustrating because it doesn't
have to be this way
and i will simply tell you that
i've always been a supporter of
universal background checks of
closing the charleston loophole of of
reinstating the federal assault weapons
ban
but the events of the past few days have
compelled me in a way and i know many
others
in a way that would be difficult for me
to describe and i give you my promise
that i will not stop as long as i have
the privilege of
serving this community and representing
this community for
i will not stop to advocate uh not stop
advocating
uh for those measures that i just
mentioned and
uh i intend to come back to this council
i hope one day soon with the news that
those measures are law
in the meantime again i would encourage
everyone on the council to the extent
that we can be a resource to
let us know our door is of course always
open
you all i think each of you have my cell
number and
certainly have jill's as well i hope
you'll reach out to us in the coming
days and weeks as
as we work to heal our community and
again as we we work to honor the victims
of this terrible tragedy i thank you for
giving me the opportunity to speak with
you and
would yield back thank you congressman
we look forward to the day that you
described as well
we would love to to thank you for
helping bring us
all kinds of gun reform so thank you
i'll turn next to um colorado state
representative
edie hooton edie
i thought i saw her
i still see her she's here you're muted
you should be able to unmute now edie oh
there we go
okay thank you um so council to the
extent that we can be
oh my goodness let us know where to
begin
of course so um you all
i think each of you have my soul mate
hang on a second hang on just one second
okay i hope you'll reach out to us i can
hear i can hear
joe speaking in the background community
yeah
that's recorded so work to honor the
victims and i'm not quite sure how to
sorry i'm looking for how to turn it off
one moment thank you congressman
we look forward to that david you
described as well
we would love to thank you for helping
bring us
all kinds of gun reform so thank you
i'll turn next to um colorado state
representative
edie hooton thank you
uh mayor weaver um and i appreciate
everyone on this card i
saw her i am i still see
her deeply what we
have that is unmuted at the moment um
i'm mute now edie
and thank you um so council to the
extent
hold on a moment i'm going to mute
everyone
so um
all right so at this point i've unmuted
everyone i've muted everyone
um so interpreters and um
council members and edie um please
unmute as you wish
thank you brenda we'll try again edie um
we'd love to hear from you
that baby you described as well
perhaps it's a problem on my end um
but i've got um i can hear
sam you know just getting the last
i wonder if you have playing in your
background the live feed
of the of the meeting it's on a slight
delay
very good and in the meantime all right
so um
brenda maybe you and i can talk offline
about how
how to stop this and
um and uh mayor you can go to someone
else
very good we'll do that so let's very
good
sorry about the technical difficulties
it's the wonder of the zoom
age so we'll turn now to um
colorado state representative judy ahmad
judy
i thank you so much uh for inviting me
to come and talk tonight
and thank you all for being here and i
you know obviously this
is a terrible event and it would be
nice if we had been able to come
together under happier circumstance
so i don't want to repeat what other
people have said
as a state legislator i am
committed to supporting
gun legislation and
be that an assault weapons ban at the
federal level at the state level
or removing the state preemption so that
every city town county in colorado can
do what they want but i think the gold
standard obviously would be to get the
federal
legislation passed i want to say that
we are so lucky here in boulder and on
this city council
to have an incredible champion for gun
rights
in council member rachel friend and
um she has really been a leader in this
topic
and i'm gonna be colluding
and collaborating with her on all the
gun measures that we talk about because
this has been a real passion area for
her and
we're so just grateful to have her
um so the other thing i want to talk
about
so thank you rachel um
is the other need that we have
which is we are not taking care of
people who have
serious mental illnesses and while most
people with mental illness
are not violent and never commit a crime
and are way more likely to be the
victims of crime
we those people are not getting the
treatment they need
either so we've had a massive failure
our state is
one of the worst in terms of its
commitment to taking care of people who
have serious mental illness
and we have agreed that it's okay
to simply jail people for mental illness
because that somehow is easier for us to
stomach
than actually putting out the resources
that we need to take care of people
and to treat people in hospitals and as
outpatients and
with compassion and we have to change
that
and that's the other thing that i am
fully committed to working on
and i hope that i will have all of your
support
and since i have this audience i'm just
going to shamelessly pitch this
i have been working for about a year now
with city and county leaders and
professionals in the mental health arena
and
councilman brockett has joined our
meetings we have sheriff kelly we have
michael doherty
and we had john tayer and the boulder
chamber
and people from mental health colorado
and people from mental health partners
people from the county and we are gonna
put a tax on the ballot for
county-wide to support mental health
resources
in boulder county and i hope you'll all
join me in supporting that it's not
going to be this year it'll be in 2022
and other counties have done it and
they've made really meaningful change
and the county that i think we should
all be looking at is larimer county
because
they're very similar to us they have
passed one of these measures
and we absolutely need to act on that
and this moment
is a moment for us to start thinking
about that
and at the state house too we have to
enact
some measures that ensure people get the
care they need
so thank you for letting me um
interject that and uh i have on all
these down items because i'm going to go
to the vigil at the courthouse
and i hope that i'll see some of you
there as well and i really appreciate
the opportunity
to to come here and speak to you and um
thank you guys for all the work you're
doing it really is
important and meaningful and
particularly right now
so thank you thank you representative
madeleine very much for that um with
that
uh edie do you want to try one more time
um yes and i'm going to try with meaning
one more time um
so in this conversation that we're
having
in this very challenging
traumatic event that just happened a
little over 48
hours ago
as policy makers you know we
are managing the incredible grief
that we are feeling personally and the
grief we feel for our community
and this is where i get choked up
because when i talk about boulder
and how tight-knit of a community we are
and the trauma that we have just
experienced um the victims
their families the employees
at king supers uh it's
just it is going to be with us
for
a long time and i think we all know that
and in this moment
to recognize that grief and that
shock um is where we want to be
but as policy makers and city council
members
included of course um
and our our federal representatives and
our statewide
uh partners
we are being called to act now
do something now and uh
judy and i have been um in a lot of
meetings
in the last 36 hours
about how we act responsibly
and not impulsively what can we do
that's really going to make a difference
not only for boulder
but for the state of colorado i mean
what happened to us on monday every city
and town that has experienced that is
being re-traumatized
which is why this is national news
it's just uh it's it's
trauma that keeps happening over and
over again
but we have to act responsibly
and thoughtfully so what we
introduce and we will be introducing
legislation
in response to this but it has to be
thoughtful which is why we're partnering
partnering with the
gifford foundation with mom-to-man
action
with every town for gun safety because
they have for
over a decade have been in the middle
of this and they know better than anyone
else
what works what doesn't work what needs
to be done
and so we will partner with them and
that will include mental health colorado
and all of our mental health partners
because as
judy as we all know on this call who is
a leader
in addressing the mental health crisis
that we have
exacerbated by covid
we can do it it's going to be
a combination of sensible
gun laws and mental health
funding and making sure that those funds
are directed
where they need to go where they make
the greatest impact
so what i just want to communicate
to everyone tonight is that
we are bolder rights we feel the pain
we take moments you know when a reporter
calls us
and oh my god judy how many calls have
we been on steve
how i mean around the world reporters
want to hear from us
and when you talk about your community
and the people in your community it's
really hard because the emotions are
right
here it's so hard to keep it together
but you have to and we want to we do it
for our community
but when we talk about action we're
going to take we can get
real clear and real calm real fast
we have partners that we can work with
we have
a state administration we have a federal
administration
we have local we have boulder county
we are so fortunate to be
working in concert with each other and
not in conflict with each other
and so judy i'll see judy at the vigil
um it's a time for
grieving remembering mourning
and also a time for action and i just
am very thank you sam for inviting us
um to join city council and i really
appreciate
the work that city council does and and
uh just you know
15 minutes ago where sam gave
a very meaningful heartfelt
recognition to the staff
that supports boulder city council
and the staffs that support the first
responders
that support king supers
that support um our
you know those who respond on the front
lines to covet
and i i just i really appreciate that
recognition
uh sam that you made because
that just amplifies how we are all in
this together
so i just thank you for the opportunity
to speak to boulder
and it's just such an incredible honor
to serve you always but especially now
thank you representative hooton very
much we will turn
next to dr george lopez but we need to
do a technical reset
on some interpretation channels briefly
so i'll turn to brenda
to walk us through that our apologies
for technical difficulties during
um this meeting everyone um we are going
to need to
turn off interpretation momentarily
and then turn it back on so
at that time so you'll see your your
language that you've chosen disappear
you'll see the globe icon return
and then you'll need to choose your
language again
we appreciate your patience while we try
this
and we are that will solve the problems
we are having
i'm turning off interpretation now
thank you i want to be sure i have all
of our
interpreters on the list because that is
the problem we were having earlier
more on the video the suspect you'll see
too okay
we are added all right we should
be able to begin again in just a moment
you should be able to choose your
language again now
please again if your language is english
we default to english but we prefer you
have chosen that language so you can
hear
anything that might be interpreted that
way as well
thank you so much sam thank you brenda
and with
that we are now going to focus a couple
of next speakers on
support for our community's mental
health
as we um walk through the fire
of the events that have happened uh so
we'll turn to dr george
ialopoulos uh he's the chief medical
officer with mental health partners here
in boulder
dr yilopoulos
you're on mute i'm sorry doctor
okay can you hear me yes yeah thank you
mayor weaver and nobody ever gets my
name right
so they call me dr e um thank you for
inviting mental health partners this
evening
uh on this incredibly sad and solemn
occasion
you know this is uh you know we are your
community mental health center
in our community and like all of you
were affected by
what's going on um we uh send our
condolences to the 10 families
and also i'm hearing stories about
mental health partners relationship with
the police officer
officer talley who was often at our
crisis center
with our citizens that needed help and
distinguished himself with his
compassion
and i'm sure we're going to hear many
other stories about the other people who
passed during this horrible
this horrible thing that happened um i
you know a lot of people uh the governor
the
the reverend the um the rabbi
uh representative nagoos others have
already said a lot of
some of what i wanted to say about
healing you know we
we two days ago we saw the worst of
mankind
we saw the worst thing happen and
already we're starting to see the best
of mankind
emerge which is often that what happens
in circumstances like this one way that
we're going to start healing
and we've already done this is making
space to come together as a community
and making space to talk about what's
going on
giving ourselves room to to be sad to be
scared to be confused and to be
angry and that's a little bit of what's
going on tonight and will continue to go
on
so we're doing it in the context of this
meeting but
we're all going to leave this meeting
and go home and we may need to be doing
some more of that
uh day-to-day for a while and i also
agree with the comments that this is
going to go on for some time
it's going to re-emerge when there's
more news about this when there's trials
when there's other shootings in the
in the nation we unfortunately have
become a community that joins a rather
terrible club
um another thing about uh
what's going on which is real
interesting and this this
rep you know this this healing this
larger community
concept there's a playbook for this
we're not the first that have been
through this
and outside organizations other mental
health centers are reaching out to us
and helping guide us about how we can
best serve the community and i bet you
similar things are happening in all of
our different roles uh for all of us on
the screen
and um and this is also
really big it's bigger than the
resources that we have at mhp
but what we're doing is we're compiling
these resources
and sometimes we're acting like an air
traffic controller
where we're bringing somebody in from
here and connecting it to
connecting them to that organization
over there who's asking
that their employees at their
organization get some help as an example
so if you feel that your organization
needs support
contact us if you
are aware of some mental health
resources that you can that you want to
donate give help out contact us and
we'll we'll help
uh find a place for that to occur um
and then uh individually uh i
reach out that's going to be real
important self-care
by the way right now is very important
it's a you know if you were
whatever you do for self-care walk
exercise
pray meditate um now is a real important
time
to continue doing that and and if you
were thinking about doing it
now is a great time to start doing that
even though you may not even feel like
doing that right now
on the screen our are
some of our services that we are the
contact numbers
for our services and uh you'll see the
um one eight four let's see i have to
move my head so i can
say the number the one eight four four
four nine three talk
number that's the state crisis line or
you can
text talk to three eight two five five
you can call our main number which is
303
443 8500 if you have
questions or you're seeking services if
you have
any other communication regarding
you know things that you might want from
the mental health center or
things that you might want to direct
towards the mental health service
mental health center hey we have reason
that we um
probably help your community to heal
contact us
on our website are some contact people
but there's really not a
wrong front door go in any door and
we'll get the information to the right
place
um the um i think those are
um oh the other thing and i don't have
it right here but it'll be on our
website
uh we have a 24 7 crisis center
uh over on airport road off of belmont
and uh so you're welcome to go over
there at any time
uh the one last thing i want to say is i
talked about reaching out
but if you you know if you're concerned
about somebody in your orbit that might
seem to be
withdrawn um having a difficult time
with this
reach out to them and you can also
contact us and ask hey what could we do
for that
um we have a couple community
um uh outreach lectures given by
our trauma expert dr janine dannenbell
and those that information will be on
the website
but in the next two days she's giving a
lecture or she's giving a presentation
entitled making it through the um making
it through together
coping with the aftermath of trauma and
it'll be tomorrow from 5 30 to 6
15 and on march 26 12 to 12 45
and um i think there will be some
questions and answers later
so um thank you for this opportunity to
speak
dr e that is much appreciated thank you
for being here tonight
um with that we'll turn next to a
recording
um another community which has suffered
from
the same kind of trauma that boulder has
just experienced is el paso texas
and um a judge from el paso reached out
to us shortly after
the events of monday and offered to give
us
his thoughts on um on
how his community coped and what they
learned so with that
if we could queue up and play the
address from judge ricardo samaniego
please
for the sake of your valuable time i
would like to read a prepared statement
good evening mayor weaver city
representatives and community of boulder
colorado
i can sincerely say to all of you that
the following heartfelt thoughts and
condolences
are truly on behalf of the entire el
paso community
we are now your brothers and sisters
united by a similar situation
on august 3rd where we lost 23 souls
from our community
we might be ahead of this imminent and
difficult healing journey
yet the challenges in the bereavement
process continues for us
as well today is red cross national
giving day
and we would love to offer support and
our commitment
to be available to help in any possible
way
i remember when we experienced our
tragedy community leaders from santa fe
texas reached out to me because of their
own
tragic experience at their local high
school
it was so surreal as they told me to get
prepared to help the next community
who would get hurt by a similar
misfortune
within 30 days midland experienced a
mass shooting
i can honestly tell you that our
community was not ready to reach out
as we are today i am confident that the
resiliency
and unity someday this leadership and
your community
will be ready to help other communities
united web el paso county created a
victims resiliency center
that has been assisting the victims and
their families throughout the entire
process
they have offered to share their
learning experiences and their best
practices to deal
with your devastating event on august
3rd 2021
we will be unveiling a community healing
garden that initiated the week after the
august third tragedy
one month prior we will be initiating a
unity
and healing month in el paso county only
in unity can we bring out the best in
humanity
and overcome the hatred in our society
that led to these terrible acts
we would be honored to have you visit us
if you'd like to learn from our journey
so that we can help with your healing
process
we encourage you to find a place in your
own community that brings back a sense
of peace
and fun memories to honor the loved ones
you lost as we did here in el paso
identifying that special place will not
only bring the community closer together
but will start you on the road to
acceptance and recovery we immediately
became known
as el paso strong the warm embrace of
our community provided the families of
the victims
a sense of hope and encouragement
that we were in this together today is
the second anniversary of deputy peter
who was senselessly
killed here in el paso so we have a
profound understanding of the laws of
officer eric talley
our heart goes out to his entire family
like deputy herrera officer talley truly
was a hero
now i'd like to read a few statements
from our community leaders here in el
paso
our mayor lisa our prayers are with you
with the effects since the sect of
violence
you now begin the difficult process of
trying to understand the nature of what
happened
and mourn the loss of your beloved
community members
we stand in solidarity and support that
we will always
encourage empathy kindness in our
communities
pete ferroni president of the el paso
county sheriff's
officer association on behalf of the el
paso county sheriff's officers
association
we are deeply saddened by the tragedy
that took place in boulder
colorado thank you officer eric talley
for your service
we pray for peace comfort and justice
for all of the victims of their families
our hearts hurt
with you deborah soluaga ceo of the
united
united way the el paso united family
resilience resiliency center
understands and is here to support and
assist the boulder community
as you navigate this difficult time like
el paso
the community of boulder is resilient
you're not alone boulder colorado el
paso stands beside you
thanks so much for that judge and i'm
sorry for the delay um bringing back up
who we have next
next we have um remarks from
uh faith leaders in our community and so
we would like to go next to tracy smith
of the islamic center of boulder
assalamu alaikum may peace be upon you
thank you for having me thank you for
listening
[Music]
as citizens of the boulder community
members of icb
do not want to take the spotlight off of
the 10 victims who lost their lives on
march 22nd
they were mothers fathers daughters
sons friends employees
and beautiful people who did not deserve
the horror and suffering they endured on
that terrible day
everyone deserves the right to safely
live their lives and without fear
our hearts are heavy and full of
compassion and sorrow
for the victims those who love them and
for
all those who experience trauma and
violence
the sad reality is right now
within the muslim community there is
fear
stress and anxiety because of the very
name
of a killer we just want to check in
with our bolder neighbors
and tell you to be mindful of your
muslim friends
i have spoken to some who are afraid to
leave the house
others who are checking out the pastor a
day with walks
women who are fearful of wearing their
hijabs in public
and men with beards who feel they're
going to be targeted
because of an increased threat of
backlash
icb has temporarily suspended our daily
prayers
the person who murdered 10 people at
king supers in boulder
does not represent the muslim community
he doesn't represent islam he just
happens to have a muslim name it
is important to remember not to
stigmatize an entire
group of people islam
teaches us to live our best lives
muslims just want to live in harmony in
their communities
if anyone would like to ask questions
about muslim life or about islam i
invite them to contact the islamic
center of boulder we are always
available
that being said the outpouring of love
and support that we have received of the
last
day or a couple of days
has been overwhelming all this kindness
is coming from a community that's
already
lost their own sweet neighbors and elder
rights still have space in their hearts
for the extra
comfort and generosity for the muslim
community
we would like to wholeheartedly thank
boulder for this kindness we're so
grateful
thank you boulder for showing up
but this is not about us we are all
residents of the city of boulder
and we feel the great pain and sadness
that runs throughout the entire boulder
community
we stand shoulder to shoulder with our
bolder neighbors in grief and solidarity
boulder police officer eric talley will
be remembered for his sacrifice
we will never forget the victims of this
terrible tragedy
if icb can help fill a gap or support
in any way please please reach out to us
thank you so much thank you ms smith
it's much appreciated um next we'll go
to
uh reverend nicole lamarche from the
community united church of christ
good evening thank you so much for
creating this space
uh we are based at the corner of table
mesa
and lehigh and southport and i regret
that we're convening for such a reason
tonight but i give thanks that this year
has taught us
how to come together creatively
across a wide geography define many
previous
limitations so thank you for holding
this space
i find that i've been at the vigils and
here tonight with sorrow and
sadness grief and groans but also in a
spirit of confession
that king supers those people this place
you are my people when i find myself
asking if i could have done more
to protect them to protect us the
employees the shoppers the first
responders
officer eric talley showed up on my
doorstep this past
june when our congregation and community
became
the victim of a hate crime that left us
reeling
he responded quickly and kindly i am
angry and deeply mourning that he is
gone for him
for his family for his seven children
and for all of us what could i have done
what could we have done to make it that
they were all still here
i also confess that i have lived the
with this mythology that many of us say
of the bolder bubble
that we are somehow separate from the
sickness of the american culture
our family came here just for that
bubble
the commitment to public schools the
arts
bike paths a love of open space a love
of justice
and now i am reminded that that was an
illusion
we are america too and if that can
happen in our paradise
there is nowhere we can hide from this i
confess
and lament for the ways that i was
complacent because of a false idea of
this sense of privilege
among our squares tonight i imagine we
have sadness shock
grief anger confusion questions and more
and like others have said i hope we can
have space for one another
to let ourselves feel whatever we need
to feel over the days weeks
months and even years ahead i know i
feel a loss
of the people and also the place it is
something like a community center for
those of us
who call this neighborhood home and for
those who seek it out
as we channel our emotions i also find
myself wondering
if this year has prepared us for exactly
what we need to do
next because this year we learned to put
our energy
our science our spiritual and material
resources
our attention our connections our prayer
and our political will
toward changing and changing fast toward
pivoting innovating
in order to save us all and we can do
that for this
too i encourage us to hold ourselves
accountable
to keep pushing to showing up with our
bodies our hearts
and our prayers to let this wound
be a window to another world
i have learned that sometimes windows
close
so we must push and pray now
may each of you who mourn tonight be
comforted
may all who fear no peace may all who
feel trauma find space to transform it
may our god of love be with you and may
hope find you
whoever you are and wherever you are
thank you reverend lamarche um and
i'll call now on uh pastor randy
spalding of the boulder
night church thank you for inviting me
to this gathering and
for including faith in our larger
response to this horrible
moment their mental church is just steps
away
from the table mesa king supers on the
corner of broadway and table mesa
we're feeling the suffering and pain of
our community
and for those of us who haven't really
directly
experienced this senseless act of
violence we cannot completely know the
pain of loved ones and friends and
family
who have been directly affected but
still we are all hurting
and many of us our faith is what gives
us a rock to stand on and enables us to
name
that deep pain and it also enables us to
respond to it with compassion
and love and care with actions that
promote healing and hope
our mennonite community is open to
anyone
in these days ahead of any faith or no
faith who just need a quiet space to
come in and meditate and pray
or to talk our faith calls us to action
as well to condemn the violence and
killing
and to work as we all want to toward a
world where people struggling mentally
or
physically or spiritually may get the
help they need
and where weapons made for killing will
one day
be made into gardening tools so that
they never used again against human
beings or any creature
most of all it's important for people to
know
that our faith communities are here to
offer compassion and care
to listen and to walk beside our bolder
community
in our belief our anger
our frustration and our sorrow
we know that the boulder community is a
resilient community
and together with you city and county
leaders and
with first responders and faith
communities
we're going to make our way forward and
we'll do it together
i wish you all healing and peace in the
days ahead
thank you thank you reverend spalding
um we'll turn next to our community
for input and we'll begin with
madeleine strong woodley of the boulder
naacp
good evening everybody and uh thank you
for having me
to uh mayor weaver our uh
city council the boulder city council
i'd also like to acknowledge my mayor
longmont mayor brian begley
as well as speaker pro tem joni joseph
and um i also represent
and i'm speaking on behalf of
the boulder police oversight task force
initially
then implementation team and now we have
in boulder vote police oversight panel
a project that we undertook
and that with the outstanding
contributions of
an amazing group of folk
we did within two years what typically
take has taken some
up to five and even more years
to to make that happen so that we're
very grateful to have been allowed to be
to have been requested and allowed to
come together and work i am going to ask
forgiveness if i uh leave anybody's name
off
uh i'd like you if you could refer to
last
tuesday's council meeting minutes
uh there was a declaration read into
the minutes uh and all of the names of
the persons that participated in that
but in the meantime i'd like to
uh honor participants todd conklin jr
our own sean ray dr michelle simpson
dr sheila davis dr
um well attorney mike rafiq
and dr james hill uh we were under the
guidance and direction very capable of
facilitation of dr carolyn
love uh pam davis
joey le pere lapari i'm sorry and city
manager amy kane
as i said forgive me if i have left
anyone out
i'd like to also acknowledge uh police
chief uh
maris harold for the work she's done
and she was hired within the time that
we came together and we supported that
effort as well
the boulder county naacp
asked if i would represent that
organization
and as a lifetime member of the memphis
branch first of all
and now the boulder county branch who we
are now
we approximately three plus years old
and we're
700 plus members strong so
if you don't know who we are you don't
know the work we're doing you don't know
our mission and our vision
please take the time to look us up
and and join us in the work that we're
doing
now needless to say the world mourns
with us the world is mourning with us
and personally at the point that i was
reaching out to
a very special asian friends for what
happened
in atlanta um two weeks ago
and that tragedy happened
to have this come this close to home
and this level of tragedy was
overwhelming and
is still overwhelming overwhelming
i'm asking that
uh well first of all i'd like to to
point out a couple of things one
is the necessity
the absolute necessity for
us to stand with our police force
and with our city leaders especially now
if you think about it we are trained and
taught to go in the opposite direction
of trouble
but these brave people are trained and
have accepted the call
to go into trouble
to protect us
for that officer
eric talley
answered that call and gave his life
for that to his
wife and those seven children
i know the days are dark i know they
have to be now
and maybe you don't see your way but
there's still
grace because you have the grace of each
other
and so now i urge you and encourage you
to lean on each other with all you got
with all the love this this life allows
we feel for you we are with you we are
all working
um in in our own ways to make sure
that we can support and provide the
support that
we're able to give you we ask that you
reach back out to us for any needs that
you're having that we're not needed
we hear our hearts are heavy
our minds and our bodies are willing
and we want you to know that if unlike
you've ever known it before
if you ever needed to lean
embrace the safety of being able to lean
now because we're here
we're here for you
i'd also ask that we
encourage and stand
for the family of the shooter we don't
know what they're going through
but we know they didn't plan on this and
so
we that kind of support is necessary as
well for the family
and the rest uh think
it will um take the course that it
it that is laid out and that it should
i want to encourage
our legislative
team uh that includes
and again forgive me if i i don't want
to call the names because i may miss
someone and that's not my heart
i would uh like to i've been watching
uh representative mcgoose lately
and uh and praying and keeping him
uplifted
as well as our governor
these are some perilous times pope folks
and we if if there's ever been a time
that we need to stand
now is that time
i also urge us all
to create our own calls to action
and make sure that those calls are
actionable
do something that's going to help
somebody
that's going to encourage somebody and
that's going to keep
this alive we must not
let tomorrow come and the sting that we
felt monday
when this first happened and it
continued
to sting we must not let that fade
this was a this is a horrific tragedy
and it stings deeply
and so i encourage everyone
don't let the sting fade keep the sting
stinging
because it's through that that we will
get the change that we so desperately
need
again i um represent
now our boulder county branch your voter
county grants
naacp specifically the boulder pool
and the boulder police oversight uh task
force implementation team the greatest
team on earth
and uh and then lastly
on behalf of my pastor senior pastor
james ray
pastor second baptist church boulder
5300 baseline road boulder colorado
80303. we
welcome you to join us
with the work that we're doing in
support of this
and in coming up with ways that can
serve to be preventive
in closing i'm asking everyone again
within the sound of my voice to reach
out to your networks
and join us standing in solidarity
to keep the sting stinging
i thank you for having me uh manager amy
kane i
appreciate you inviting me and um
thank you everyone within the sound of
my voice have a great evening
thank you ms woodley much appreciated
with that
we will next go to um amy nelson
thank you for having me here today um as
i
prepared to speak here today um i had a
loss of words and i'm
grieving and i text friends and asked
how do i do this without crying
and they told me i don't that my love
for my community and then my love for my
students
today i get to show up as my authentic
self and my community
so that's what i'm gonna do which means
i'm probably gonna go over two minutes
because i'm gonna have to pause and let
the tears flow but
um know that these tears are the love
that i have for this community and the
pain that i feel
so they know that we're all feeling um
i'm going to try to read um because it's
the only way i know to get through this
i've been at a loss of words since
monday when my 17 year old daughter told
me there was an active shooter at the
king supers near fairview where i worked
for four years
a school that i still serve in my
current role
my mind immediately went to denny stong
denny was my student for three years
it was december of the senior year after
weeks of helping him complete
applications the colleagues and i
celebrated him being offered
a position at king supers
where he worked until monday
i wish i could describe to you how he's
how excited it was
he was to share the good news to join
that role to be that role in the
community
there's so many memories like this one
i've tried desperately to bring to the
surface ever since
many colleagues and former students have
reached out and shared photographs and
memories amongst their condolences
some make me laugh some make me smile
most fill my eyes with tears
i thought about the santa hat denny war
every day of december
every year that i taught him the speaker
he carried down the halls during passing
periods and drive everyone crazy with
his old soul
or holiday music i thought about how
honored he was and how he always kept me
on my toes
i thought about my colleagues who
described their favorite part of going
to the local store was running into
denny
i thought about how much he'd love to
tease me but if you know me you know i
teased him right back
most people in boulder are impressed by
my sneaker game denny questioned my
choice in footwear and would laugh
hysterically at my white jays or forces
and ask why would anyone buy
white shoes then there's my first day as
a teacher at fairview high school
i gave the fir the typical first day of
school speech i told the students how
committed i was to being an educator how
it was going to be a great year
how much i cared about each one of them
denny
had the audacity to challenge me he cut
me off and told me i was going to have
to prove it to him
but during our celebration on his last
day of high school
i'm sorry
as we laughed cried and joked about all
the memories we'd made during those
years
i reminded him of the first day we met
we laughed when i told him he'd ruined
my speech and he laughed and said well
it worked you earned my trust and
respect
on monday night i tweeted i'm literally
terrified to learn the
other nine names my friend and colleague
called me tuesday morning to tell me the
news
denny was one of the names she told me
exactly what i was terrified to hear
everything after that was a blur the
emotions were too big
i should add that i just attended two
student funerals from a car accident
just
just over two months ago and i'm still
grieving those losses
this felt and still feels like too much
but in her own grief my friend knew i
needed support she immediately made
calls and colleagues and former
colleagues
all vaccinated rushed to be with me i
received more phone calls and messages
that i can count
friends came to just sit with me others
brought food to encourage me to eat or
care packages for my swollen eyes
i share this for a reason because as i
think about boulder's collective healing
i encourage you to think about all
members of our community
i know others are grieving in the same
ways that i am whether personally
connected to the lives lost during this
senseless act of violence on monday
the entire community is grieving we must
hold space to grieve for ourselves and
for each other
we must care for the families that are
most directly impacted
but we also must think about how we
collectively care for each other
denny stone
it's not lost to me that many are using
the hashtag boulderstrong and denny's
last name was
originally misspelled as strong since
names are announced we've heard
witnesses speak to denny's heroic
efforts
there's not a doubt in my mind that
these accounts are true
a friend who also cares deeply about
denny texts me and asks
why would he run too instead of away
from the gunshots amy
well i may wish the same i know that's
not denny's character
died a hero thank you for saying his
name
thank you for remembering him as the
hero he was
did he was feisty but he cared deeply
and had a soft heart underneath that
tough exterior
boulder is denny strong but only if we
collectively care for each other and our
community and the ways that denny
clearly did
take care of yourselves take care of
each other boulder
thank you thank you ms nelson
um next uh we are checking on
whether tina marquis is here but we'll
move now
to harman zuckerman as we bring tmn
carmen thanks sam
um first of all i'd like to thank city
council for holding
on this special meeting to help our
community cope with what happened on
monday at the table mesa king supers
and i want to recognize you mayor sam
for the way you've represented our city
and you've been called to speak on this
tragedy um
by so many local national and even
international news agencies
um i attended an online vigil last night
which was put on by
boulder's rabbinical community and one
thing i
heard really stuck with me and i'll
share it
it was said by rabbi fred green of
congregation hashem
rabbi green spoke of the way people in
the face of tragedy tend to ask
how could god have let this happen
he acknowledged that this is natural but
that he believed that in moments like
ours
god is simply grieving along with all of
us
the message i took from this is the
tragedies
like accidents happen and when they do
we have to collectively grieve and do so
with the intention of coming closer
together as a community
like so many of you the table mesa king
supers for me
is my market besides my home and office
it's the place i visited the most
in all of boulder as an avid cook and
someone who once worked as a stock boy
in a market
i find the american supermarket to be a
world of wonders
and i appreciate what it takes to keep
one running
since covid i have rarely let the
opportunity
pass to tell staff at king supers how
much i appreciate
the skill and the courage that they've
gifted us with
just by doing their jobs
i have called them heroes and now
these workers and our neighbors
which is really one community together
our community
has been visited by a terrible event
and suffered an unspeakable loss
let us grieve together with the
intention
of coming closer together
let us hold each other and let us fully
feel our loss
to make room for the long road
of healing that stretches in front of us
thank you so much herman next we will
turn to
tina marquis she's the president of the
boulder valley
school district board of education tina
hi thank you for organizing this event
and inviting me to participate
at the boulder valley school district we
are so saddened by this tragic event
and we're even more disappointed that
gun violence
and the fear of gun violence is a part
of our students
everyday lives now more than ever
in response to the event the boulder
valley school district has activated its
trauma support teams
and is helping to provide resources to
help our families
and our staff and our community
talk about this event with their
children you can find them on bvsd.org
we understand how much our families are
going through and particularly the
families in south boulder
we know that we're going to need time to
think about these events
we know that parents and students and
staff will have questions in the coming
weeks and months
and as a district we'll be creating this
space to have those conversations
especially as we return to in-person
learning
in the next week again we send our
condolences to the families
and we are so deeply saddened by what's
happened in our community and we're here
to help
please reach out to the district if you
need a partner
and resources thank you
thank you tina um next we'll hear from
pierce limbits who is a fifth grader at
bixley
thank you for hearing my words i'm
pierce lemons and i'm a fifth grader at
bixby school in south boulder
i am outraged by the mass shooting in my
grocery store
it should not have happened and i am
very sad for the victims families
the victims could have been any one
of us even my mom who does her grocery
shopping before she picks
me up from school at 3 15.
the other person the person who did
this should never have done it and
should never have had a gun
how many people have to die before we
understand this
this this grateful
sorry i am grateful for the people
and the police officers who stopped this
especially
eric talley who gave his life
we will never recover from this until we
know
it will never happen again i am 11 years
old
and i think everyone should do their
best to fix this
it is unimaginable how the f
how the victims families are feeling
and no one should ever have to go
through something as tragic as this
please keep us safe in the future
thank you pierce um
let's see uh next we will call on
soraya latif
nixie thank you so much your words and
your presents have so much power i
really appreciate hearing from you
hi everyone i invite you all to just
take a moment to take a deep breath
in and take a deep exhale out
and just acknowledge that your breath is
there and that you are alive at this
moment with all of its grief
and its immensity that you are here
breathing
i am an asian black indigenous immigrant
woman
i have an islamic name i grew up in
muslim households
and i'm in a healing and inherently
political body
and then a body that has truthfully
rarely felt safe in this country
including while living in boulder i'm a
cu boulder alum
and i co-lead a youth-led civic
engagement program called public
achievement in boulder working with 200
middle and high school youth
and 60 cu students the shooting
for our students followed a super
spreader riot
on the university hill a mass shooting
just last week in
atlanta and a semester in a pandemic
without any break
the university has asked us to continue
to hold classes
ask students to still show up following
this we're going without rest
and without time to process and we're
working really hard to hold space with
what feels like
not much institutional support this is
the true experience of many of our
students
heroes of this moment are students who
are leading boulder valley's mutual aid
work
who got groceries to those experiencing
trauma in the last 48 hours after monday
and the healers and educators who have
centered community care in the midst of
a pandemic
and multiple mass shootings i also
really value the stories
and the commitments shared here today by
our leaders and community members on
this call
and i guarantee you that my students are
going to continue to hold
all of us here accountable to what we're
promising
for years my students have organized on
the urgency of addressing gun violence
in our country so that its horrors did
not arrive here in our community
knowing fully well that it could my
students and i often remind ourselves
that we
are the ones we've been waiting for
because nobody else is going to rescue
us young people
every day have to tell themselves this
at this moment and this remains our
story of now
three years ago students at fairview
high school one of them my sister
just over a mile away from the king
supers organized a walkout
around gun violence in our country and
today when i was speaking with her she
said if this shooting had happened on a
school day
pre-covered 19 that that store would
have been filled with high school
students hanging out
i sat recalling sandy hook columbine we
are not immune
i sat thinking of trayvon martin and
brianna taylor
i am not immune we have talk of
returning to normal
following vaccines but we know that
trauma leads to overproduction of stress
and stress hormones that when activated
do not allow us to return to normal for
long periods of time
my api students and their loved ones
have expressed not wanting to leave
their houses for the last few weeks
and now what does it mean to wake up in
this country
following what happened last week and on
monday
how do we heal when moments feel so
compounded
when these issues feel so pervasive and
what do we each do with that
precious breath that we got to wake up
today and hold
i invite you to ask yourself and i ask
myself this daily
am i in a daily practice of witnessing
who is not represented
in any spaces i work in whose breath is
no longer with
us whose rights to freedom or dignity
might we be actively
contributing to reducing through our
choices
ask what is needed for every identity
and body to feel safe
have we each questioned how that safety
might look and mean different things
from our own
safety this is one of the most pervasive
issues
gun violence of my generation and still
nothing prepares you for the hours you
try
spending to hear back from if your
students and your colleagues and your
best friends are okay
and safe and alive and to see if there's
a name on a list you might recognize and
then attempt to process
all of the moving parts of how we got
here so all the families and community
of those who are lost i'm so sorry
and i love you this has been regarded as
a once-in-a-lifetime shooting in boulder
yet we know gun violence has taken so
many lives in this country
we're living through what many would
call a once-in-a-lifetime pandemic
yet we know that in access to health
care and resources
racism and caste kills people across our
country and our world
daily without there being a cove at 19.
we know this and we don't heal by
viewing our wounds as isolated and
insulated
we heal by learning holding and acting
on behalf of how the issues
and lack of previous action connect and
perpetuate
systems and a culture that can reinforce
harm rather than prevent it
rather than treating each other as a
community
may we not wait to be in community only
after tragedy
but may we practice community every
single day
i told my students in a healing circle
this morning
don't let this slip and move past us
like madeline was saying earlier
keep the sting singing violence
shouldn't have to arrive at our door for
us to care
but sadly it did let us commit
each of our breaths to hold space for
our community to build resources for
free therapy
to not define freedom as free for only
one kind of person
may we push institutions to allow room
for being human
and an unimaginable moment of
overlapping inequity
and give us time for self-care and
community care
may we not separate our healing from our
politics and may we always believe that
where there is community
and where there are people there is
healing to be found
and may we not perpetuate any further
pulling away from one another
but show solidarity to our islamic
community our new divergent communities
may we remember that these were whole
lives lost and that we have a duty to
protect each other
and walk home together safely may we
commit
and i mean please deeply commit our
breath
to imagine a world and thus a community
such as this
that is unlike the current status quo
and to not stop the work
at what others won't allow when it means
safer communities for all of us
thank you so much for your time thank
you soraya
next we will go to christine chin who is
a
new member of the human relations
commission
christine thank you mayor weaver and
thank you to city council for inviting
me to speak tonight
one week and one day ago you appointed
me to the human relations commission
and as i was watching city council
proceedings on my television i also had
my laptop open
and was reading the news about what was
happening in atlanta
which was eight days ago today
as the news unfolded i learned that
of the eight people who were killed six
of them were asian women
three of them were over the age of 60.
on monday i went to my parents home
to speak with them about rising
anti-asian violence
and to ask them to please take care when
they went to the grocery store
a couple of hours later i saw the news
that at my own grocery store
less than a mile away from my home there
was a gunman
on the loose
i come here today as a member of the
community as a two-time member of the
boulder community
i grew up here in the 80s and my
grandmother
lived on darley just a couple of blocks
from the table mesa king supers
she used to go to esl classes at the
paddock center which is now community
montessori
and she would take me to king supers and
i would ride the mechanical horse for a
penny
and i would get my free cookie from the
bakery
when i moved back to boulder two and a
half years ago
i came to give my children
the community that i have experienced
here growing up
and i chose to move to table mesa
because i knew that community
and during this pandemic as with
most everyone else in the neighborhood
it's pretty much been the only place
i've spent any time with any regularity
besides the walls of my own home
my kids rode the penny horse before they
had to put it away when co would broke
out
they get free cookies from the bakery
just last saturday i stepped in to buy a
balloon
for a five-year-old neighbor and the
young man
who was at the registry waited extremely
patiently while i took an eternity to
decide whether i wanted to get a gold
balloon
or a silver balloon on a regular basis
terry bagged my groceries
yesterday i decided to walk to king
supers to
bring some flowers and pay my respects
and
on my walk there i ran into a neighbor
who was outside
who is an elderly asian man who's lived
in the community for decades
and we spoke and he
we spoke about what happened on monday
and we also spoke about
the rising violence against asians and
we spoke about atlanta
and he said to me even though he's been
in this country
probably about 50 years like my parents
he said to me that he's afraid to go out
he said to me he's afraid to be seen in
public with other elderly asians
because it's become too dangerous
i bring all these threads together
because we are all
members of multiple communities all of
us here are members of the boulder
community
some of us are asian-american others are
black
others are developmentally disabled like
the many employees of king supers and
table mesa
others have purple hair for some reason
so many of the employees at king
sleepers died they heard blue and purple
and it brought me such joy every time i
i went
and i hope it will again when i go again
we're all members of many different
communities and we're also
all facing many pandemics and many
epidemics
we have a global health pandemic right
now we have an epidemic of racism
we have an epidemic of gun violence
as our community moves on and tries to
heal
i hope that we can all recognize that we
all come from many different communities
that we can hold space for each other
that we can listen
that we can be there for each other and
we can all learn to move forward
together
thank you thank you christine
next we'll call on lojo hamoi
i'm sorry if i mispronounced that um
is director of public relations for the
community organization
mojo mai thank you so much uh
amir wave for giving me opportunities
uh all first of all
saying that it's a grateful
for me to be here especially the city of
boulder council to invite me
and i would like to send my condolences
to the community who have lost their
life
in timely manner and is the community of
boulder
who endure the grief were qualified
and you are terrified so
me as a bowler resident
i do go to use king super to do shopping
i i take my kids
at the king super the very king super
my my kids are picking whatever they
want
ice cream whatever they want
i go shopping on sunday in the same king
super
now i'm so horrified my kids are
terrible and i feel unsafe
i'm working here in poland
bola school school district
i'm worried of the kids
next week they are coming back to school
every day we attend the security meeting
on how to
to keep the school the kids innocent
kids in a school itself
so it's very unfortunate situation
our resident of polar right now
especially
african-americans every day
who are hearing gun violence killed
so i scared when we had that thing on
monday
i called my wife i was at the school i
was asking why the kids
and where are the members who are
calling every members
where they are make sure that
you are safe because the news of gun
violence
and racism is really
terrifying our community especially
african americans
who are here in pola county for the last
15 years
and we never given any opportunity
to our grievances
monday shooting he's just so
terrifying and was scared to go
yesterday i went to the king super
to shop for my kids because my kid could
not be in the house without food
without me i have to go
every one of us in the king super we are
not looking at each other
on eyes because we are scared
i'm happy that our governor our
representatives they were able to attend
these
special meetings of our community to
share their sorrows
and their love and prayers to the family
especially the policemen who have
paid ultimate christ to keep herself
to keep my family safe my kids and polar
residents
schools i hope it is time
that we engage ourselves
especially community policing leadership
structure and to work with the law
enforcement
so that we identify
situations and make the techniques that
will help us to solve problems within
the families within the community
within our youth inclusive leadership
where we can engage ourselves and
dialogue among ourselves
because we are the community each and
every day
asian american indians
uh black everyday
stories killing president i hope
will open uh inclusive leadership
engagement dialogue
network information sharing so that
such barbaric act within our community
to not be existing
let's work together we need equitable
uh community social work and social
gatherings
to discuss and engage ourselves in
areas where we see the lazy locals
so as a director of public relations
within our
here in boulder so who are looking
forward to work together
the community of bowler councils
and mayor to make sure that we engage
our community
our students because there is a lot of
mental issues going on
without condemning economic issues
these were the avenues or situation of
such
like monday arising we need to make sure
that
we treat those things because we're
engaging each other
because i'm still now at the workplace
right now as the duck is getting
getting in i'm scared too because
i don't know who is behind me who is
next to me
because i have to go and see my kids i
have to go
so let's work together join with our
lost
enforcement work together let's help
them
to make sure that we share information
whatever the situation that you are in
share the information with borla city
council
mental health is growing so i'm very
highly welcome
to any support whatever we can do to
discuss and engage our community our
kids to teach our kids
to love and let's stand with the family
who have lost their loved ones let's
pray with them
whatever resource that we have here in
our
ebola community the african community
who are able to
extend and to work together in
solidarity to make sure that we achieve
what we want
to make this community safe and better
and friendly thank you so much man for
inviting me and i appreciate to to work
with you
whatever way you wanted our community to
engage in thank you so much i appreciate
it and
uh city bola city council thank you so
much appreciate it
next we have jeff cahoon from the
boulder area labor council of the
afl-cio
thank you mayor weaver thank you city
council for holding this meeting
i i have to start by observing the fact
that of
the ten victims four were union members
three from cave supers and of course our
brother
officer tully um
that it's it's painful to observe
but as as a leader of an organization
that's on more than 140 years old
uh success basically is successive to
the
lewisville labor council founded in the
uh 1860s
um we've observed a lot of
pain and suffering and massacres
and recognize that for what it is
it was it was a massacre generally
because
we were fighting for worker threats
and all of these workers and working
people
and the small business people that were
slaughtered senselessly
um at king supers
remind us of how we handle this in the
history of labor
and the way we do it is um
really quite basic is we recognize we
have to address
issues and we fight and we lose
and we fight and we lose and we fight
and we win
we have issues in front of us i think
they're clearly identified by
our um our public servant friends
mental health is an enormous issue
and one that is underfunded and that we
can work on
gun safety is an enormous issue
and one we can work with and one
we could solve the history of labor
tells us
we have to work on issues
with any sort of
excuse me there you go i think we have
them muted now go ahead
jeff there you go so
what i'm going to suggest is something
that was suggested originally
by a very famous labor leader named joe
hill
joe was a labor organizer that was
basically assassinated on trump
charges by the state of utah back in
1910
but we've had ludlow that we've had to
recover from
and we've had the columbine mine
massacre
that where the graves for those might
the 11 miners that were killed by the
state police in 1926
are in lewisville lafayette and the last
of joe hill's ashes
are scattered around the graves of the
workers
in the lafayette cemetery
and joe hill taught us something his
last words
don't mourn organize
and around these issues we can and
that's how we respond
to a tragedy like this let us work
together
to fund mental health and help people
like the killer that slaughtered us
not to to be able to find peace
let us work together to deal with gun
safety
as a broad issue and let us recognize we
may have to fight
and lose and fight and lose before we
fight and win
but that this is the way we memorialize
our loss
and this is the way we can make a
difference moving forward
thank you mayor weaver thank you jeff um
with that we are going to see brenda i'm
going to check in
chris and pam are at the
vigil that's being held and we're going
to have them bring in three people from
that vigil
if they'd like to speak to us um
are you ready to go to that or should we
have another speaker first
so it looks like chris speaking my mind
is a little bit more difficult in front
of you all
um but i've given a lot of thought you
know to
[Music]
our circumstances and listen to us all
debate what the answers are and
it does not seem that it's an either or
answer um you know in america we have a
tendency to value human life on net
worth
and if you don't have net worth you're
not worth anything
and you know depression is up
suicide is up addiction is up and mass
shooting is up
and it's time we really examine what our
values and
we see this community and people do come
together and as a whole i don't think
americans as a whole but as a culture we
have to face this aspect of
our of our social construct of what we
value
and i don't know that we can just focus
on
gun control or gun regulation is one
option i don't think that's the only
answer
i don't think it's just mental health
although there are not enough beds
for people who need help there are no
beds
um we also have to look at wealth
disparity
and a living wage in this country
those are things that help agitate
and and create violence
so i don't know that i have all the
answers at all but
you know as i think about and i listen
to us all debate
what we need to do we need to
make america equitable and a healthy
place
people can go get a bed if they're
struggling or can get mental health care
we don't have people with ak-15s
and that people can make a living wage
so i really appreciate mutual aid being
out here i'm a big supporter of mutual
aid they do a lot
for the community and i appreciate y'all
letting me
spout off thank you
my name's jenny and i think music is a
great healer
if anyone would please join me
in a bob dylan song of blowing in the
wind
if you can all look it up on your phones
google it i don't want to sing alone
i'll give you a second
okay anyone that's been in boulder long
enough will know the song
or if you've been to
blue grass
how many roads must a man
walk down
you called my man
here and tonight i'm going to be
speaking on it for just a few minutes
on a more personal level jodie waters
victim number 10 was my sister mr wreck
she called her her soul sister rock she
called her her soul sister
jody always had her back
actually the funny thing about jody was
we didn't even in my family know her
last name
she was even in my contacts in my phone
as just
jody but that'll change for us this week
i got a call from my sister on monday in
the late afternoon
madeline was getting really worried she
hadn't heard from jody since earlier
that day
since before the shooting and jody lived
right across the street from that table
mesa
king supers and madeline knew that she
shopped there almost every day that was
her store like it was so many people's
store
stores and since the shooting her
daughters had not heard from her
and madeline had not heard from her and
nobody heard from her
and then i texted my sister at 4 30 p.m
and i said madeline did you hear from
jody and she said she had it
and then i texted her at 5 30 and she
still had it
and then my daughters texted madeline at
six and then at seven and we still heard
nothing
but by this time a deep sense of dread
began to fill my family we all went to
sleep that night not knowing
my sister madeline was still hoping for
the best but then
in the early hours of the morning on
that tuesday we got the news that jody
was one of the 10 victims and it was so
so devastating for us
and i'm just the sister of jody's best
friend
and it was devastating for me i can't
even imagine
how her family felt her daughters who
she was so close to and who texted her
every day and how all the families of
victims felt that night
going into tuesday morning waiting for a
phone call
and so when people from all over the
city and the country and even in the
world i got
i got a call from the mayor of vermont
negev asking how i was and
is the family okay and i said to each
one of them
we're not okay i am not okay
the city is not okay none of us are okay
in this community is certainly not okay
and what happened is not okay but you
know what
at this time what tragedy does is kind
of it's
it's kind of interesting it brings
people together
so whereas there was where there could
be strife in the community
now we're all one and we're working
together as one
and when people are one they can
accomplish so much more
and so i don't want to give up hope on
humanity
and i won't give up hope on this city
none of us will
but we will stand together and we're
gonna do
do what jody did and we're gonna have
each other's back
thank you thank you tara
um juni are you ready or
great um so um councilmember joseph is
going to read a letter and explain
what the letter is about judy
thank you very much mayor weaver
we received a letter from um
you know from the university of colorado
boulder student government
cusg and the letter
is to the community
today we remember and honor the lives of
denis strong
[Music]
suzanne fountain kevin
mahoney murray
judy waters and officer
eric talley our deepest sympathies go
out
to the lives lost and those
directly impacted by the horrific events
that transpired on march 22nd
at king supers and boulder
the 10 victims who lost their lives were
friends
families and neighbors of our community
this this reprehensible act of violence
is one that will inevitably affect our
community
for the foreseeable future
we recognize the lifelong impact
that this will have on those affected by
this tragedy
thanks to the swift action of the
boulder police department
and additional regional law enforcement
agencies
further loss of lives were prevented
the the herrick act of officer tally
as the first officer on the scene
demonstrates
the commitment that our first responders
have in protecting our community from
egregious
acts of violence
today we want to recognize the immense
amount of pain
that our community is enduring
it is okay to mourn and grieve
it is okay to feel confused and hurt
we offer our deepest condolences to
those who are
experiencing these emotions as students
and members of the boulder community
we share these heartaches and grieve
alongside our community members
as cu students it is
our responsibility to not only support
each other
but to support a greater bolder
community during times of adversity and
heartache such as these
we must lean on each other
we recognize that individuals are all
experiencing pain
and griefs and grief in their unique
ways
our community will be gathering at
fairview high school
this thursday march 25th at 6 30 pm
for a kindle like vigil any and all
are welcome let us honor and remember
the 10 lives
lost following march 22nd
as a community member we will not let
hatred prevail
instead let us foster love compassion
and unity and this letter was from
molly from it the student body president
isaiah chivas student body president
george conway student body president
abby henson judicial branch chief
justice julia foley legislative council
president
and also the students wanted to let
community member knows
if you're seeking individual support
it would encourage you to engage with
the following university resources
that are free of charge the office of
victim assistance
which provide free and confidential
support
consultation advocacy
information and short-term counseling
services
to students graduate students
faculty and staff who are experiencing a
traumatic
disturbance or life disruptive event
students can call 303-492-8855
to connect with the office of victims
assistance counselor
or to receive services 24 7. they can go
to
https
www.colorado.edu
ova and also there's the counseling and
psychiatric services
which is the counseling and psychiatric
available for
telehealth which is virtual counseling
appointments
and support services including crisis
support
student can call 303-492-2277
student can also visit e let's talk
for an informal and confidential
consultation with
a counselor which is at www.colorado.edu
counseling and again this is a letter
from
a student from the university
and i just also would like to apologize
um
part of it is my accent as well when i
was saying the name of the victims
i did not pronounce them well enough i
apologize for that and um
thank you very much sam thank you junie
for that
and thank you to the cu student
government for
putting out that letter um next
uh we will go to david gross who is a
professor at the university as well as a
former regent candidate david
hi uh thank you for the opportunity to
speak tonight uh yeah my name is dave
gross
and i've lived in boulder for 25 years
i'm a member of the cu faculty i'm a
husband
son-in-law and father of two kids all
here
i'm devastated and heartbroken by this
this mass murder committed here in our
home
so i'd like to take a minute to speak
about guns
my training is as an economist and so
i'll use this time to speak about guns
from that perspective
when we teach economics the first thing
we teach is that everyone acting in
their own best interests produces the
best outcome
and then the second thing we teach is
that's not really true
and the main reason it's not true is
negative externalities
the best example of a negative
externality is of course pollution it
may be best for me to produce some
product in the cheapest way possible but
if the effects of my production are so
deleterious to the community
and the pollution i create dominates the
benefit of uh the product or
even the lower price we would all deem
it perfectly reasonable to restrain my
activity to restrict my freedom to
mitigate this harm
well people who choose to own guns
obviously derive benefit from gun
ownership
in that first principle of economics
everyone acting on their own best
interests
producing the best outcome is often
cited as a justification not to restrict
individual freedoms
but that second principle the negative
externalities must also be applied
it's impossible for me to detail the
magnitude and dimensions
of the negative impact that unrestricted
gun ownership
visited on me personally my family my
friends and all the members of this wide
community
the hurt the harm experienced by the
hundreds of thousands of members of the
boulder community
and officer talley's seven children and
all of the other victims families
clearly outweighs any and all benefits
of unrestricted gun ownership we must
restrict
gun ownership right now these negative
externalities these threats became
just too great thank you for the
opportunity to speak tonight
thank you david next we'll turn to
tashiana hernandez
of the community foundation of boulder
tatiana you're muted you
uh thank you mayor weaver and all of
boulder city council for
the opportunity to speak with our
community tonight at such a dark time
our hearts and deepest sympathies are
with the friends and families
of the beloved friends and neighbors we
lost and with everyone who is suffering
tonight
your community foundation is here to
support the needs of our community
and we have received an outpouring of
support from colleagues at community
foundations in dayton ohio
el paso san antonio texas and ventura
california
who are lending us their guidance and
sharing their experiences
so that we can best serve the needs of
our community at this time
unfathomably there is expertise in our
world
when it comes to responding to events
like this
it is also sad consolation that we have
a partner in our state with expertise
on how to best respond to the needs of
those most directly affected
we are working closely with the colorado
healing fund so that together
we can help ease the burden of monday's
horrific events
for those victims we also we're also
working in partnership with the city
our local nonprofit community and others
to provide financial support
where it's needed in a responsive and
transparent way
and in that spirit of transparency i
want to share with you what we know
now regarding how funds raised by the
community foundation will support
our community if we think about the
needs of our community
as concentric circles of proximity at
the core
are the needs of families who lost loved
ones
this core is where our partnership with
the colorado healing fund is of utmost
importance and where the majority of the
funds we raise will go
the next circle of proximity includes
those who experienced
the event first hand colorado healing
fund
in partnership with the colorado
organization for victims assistance will
define where their support ends
within that second circle and where our
support can begin
and the third circle is our entire
community
we have suffered a collective trauma and
it will take
time to understand and process our grief
our community has short and long term
needs and we will continue to work with
our partners to respond to
and hold space for the full scale of our
loss
we will get through this together and we
will do so by leaning on each other
we will get through this by remembering
every person we lost
and love every person we need even more
and in closing i'll say
let our aching hearts be a testament to
the depth of love that we have
for each other and for our community
thank you all so much thank you tajiana
next we'll go to nicki mccord um
who i believe was recently appointed to
one of the city's boards nikki
thank you for inviting me to speak i
carry this responsibility with respect
for the victims and for my community
this was difficult for me to write
how do i pay respect to the victims of
this mass shooting
including the loss of life of a police
officer
and share my fears about what our
response to this tragedy
could mean for people who look like me
my attempt at striking this balance will
begin with me reading the names of the
victims and then going into my remarks
denny stonk nevin
stanisek ricky olds
jelana bartkowiak
fountain terry liker
eric talley kevin mahoney
lynn murray jody waters
right now we as a community do not feel
safe
and we may be willing to do anything to
regain that sense of safety
so we're asking ourselves we're asking
people in positions of power to take
action
for many in my community the action that
needs to happen to regain their sense of
safety
comes in the form of police presence the
good guys with guns
protecting them from whatever harm could
come their way
heroically demonstrated in the actions
of officer talley
who gave his life to protect the safety
of those
still in king supers for me
in the normal course of my daily life
based on my shared identity with brianna
taylor
corinne gaines ayanna stanley jones
tatiana jefferson my sense of safety
does not lie
in the hands of those good guys with
guns
the exact same people my neighbors rely
on
for their safety so what do we do
what do we do as a community to regain
our sense of safety
well the answer does not lie in inaction
what we do and more importantly what you
do
is act in a way that is brave act in a
way that takes you out of your comfort
zone
act in a way that may make you unpopular
act in a way that may make you lose your
position of power
because this community is hurting and we
don't feel safe
and acting in whatever way that provides
safety for all of us
who live in this 30 square miles
surrounded by reality
is what will have a lasting positive
impact
on those of us who call boulder colorado
home thank you thank you nikki
next we have markeisha k
higgin one of our community connectors
thank you so much for the opportunity to
speak here today and i'll try to keep it
brief
so i'd like to start by first giving my
condolences to all who have been
affected
by this tragedy in preparation for me
speaking here today
i made a list of some of the sentiments
that reflect
how i and many that i have heard from
in the community have been feeling and
i'd like to share that with you now
heartbroken exhausted
traumatized frustrated
how do i explain what happened to my
kids
concerns about retribution towards
certain minority groups
desperate for change yet not optimistic
that it will take place
as these next days turn to weeks and
months
i hope that when i look back at this
list
and reflect on where we as a community
in our journey of healing and moving
forward
that these words will be replaced with
words
such as love hope
safe inclusivity
community led change that this time
it was different that we circumvented
the politicized issues that have stopped
real change in the past
and were able to create meaningful
people-focused
solutions thank you thank you markeisha
next uh we have ingrid castro campos
gracias one of the city council members
community leaders
and beloved community members i hope my
words
i hope that my words honor the suffering
of others
and the lives we have lost there's a
part of me that wishes to address the
truth
of the horrors that underline such a
violent event
and yet i'm choosing to sit within the
mess of it all
and my own suffering i know better that
out of chaos
and unresolved suffering fragmentation
and event-led action steps only
perpetuate dysfunction
and harm we need to come together
and examine our filters and biases that
prevent us from looking deeply
into how we got here in the first place
in my experience here and in the country
my country of origin
acts of violence are rooted in
fragmentation
that fragmentation might look like
numbness a sense of
normalcy over social flaws that
are against the basic life order in
human rights
fragmentation might also look as the
moral chaos
of having misaligned priorities valuing
profits revenues
egos politicized views inequities
over people and humanity
i implore you all to move towards action
that repairs fragmentation by
resensitize those areas of ourselves
that are numb we can allow for this mass
shooting
or any act of hate to become
another unfortunate event in the u.s
history
not just another act of violence in our
town
nor the world i implore you all to move
towards action that repairs
fragmentation
by assuming collective responsibility
in work at a grassroots level and for
legislation
that protects the true freedoms of
citizens
not the freedoms that are sold to us is
logical
but instead those should be rooted in
accordance to the illnesses and
strengths
of our society we must act as certainly
and steadily
i implore you to move towards action
that repairs fragmentation
by doing anything and everything within
our power your power to close gaps in
ineffective systems related to mental
health
access to resources to meet basic needs
and the well-being of community members
finally i implore you to move towards
action that repairs fragmentation by
bringing community together
not out of the urgency of the moment but
to heal from the long-lasting effects of
violence
i you we cannot allow for our community
to continue
to operate from fragmentation we cannot
forget
that we only have this moment to make
things right to each other
and those who have left us too soon
we cannot do it on our own healing
restoring and supporting each other
only occurs in community we must
and only can move forward from a place
of empathy
and love rooted action thank you for
inviting me and listening to
my work thank you thank you ingrid
um next we have norma johnson
thank you um thank you everyone for
bringing us all together and for
creating this opportunity
for our community um
you know there's there's a couple of
things that
uh i want to talk about and one of them
is uh just talking about
bringing us together just to acknowledge
what it takes for
uh for all the departments for all the
agencies for all the people
uh to come together to create something
like this uh the same thing
that happened during the tragedy at
king super just watching all those
components
of agencies and individuals coming
together
under amazing organization
to keep us safe
so i just wanted to acknowledge that
that
these things don't just happen that so
much is put into them
and um i and i i give so much thanks for
that
the other thing i want to speak to is
um belonging
um you know
everything that i've been hearing
people talk about this evening
it kind of funnels down to belonging
who belongs who feels
they belong who doesn't feel
they belong
is at the root of so much you know i'm a
storyteller a poet a social justice
advocate
and facilitator and i have
so many i'm in so many conversations
about equity and justice
and it it always comes down to that
it's the everyday things that we
experience
that create the bigger things in our
lives
so so one i want to put a reminder out
for that
and as people have been speaking to that
this evening
[Music]
feeling what they're feeling that's
that's all those things that
make the bigger stuff those are all the
things that
count it's always the little things
and um it's the little things that make
the laws
eventually so
you know i talk a lot about everyday
race
and everyday healing
and that's something that we are
experiencing
in this moment and it's something we're
going to be experiencing for a long time
so i i just want to encourage us to give
ourselves permission for that
and also along with that belonging is
honesty
because so much of what has happened in
our country
has to do with a foundation of
dishonesty
and honesty is something that we all can
grow and um evolve
in and it changes things
because in order to have trust there
must be
honesty so
um you know that belonging uh
for me it's it's been happening in in
just
those small encounters every day
you know i was in another grocery store
and um yesterday and i was
in the meat department and the
person that waited on me she
we just started talking because
it was in the air and because we're
feeling it
i stood there for maybe 15 minutes
there was no one else no other customer
behind me and we just
talked about the feeling of this
the grieving and she spoke about how
she knew officer talley and how
what a kind and beautiful person he was
and he affected her life and i stood
there
holding my package of meat
and realized that this was maybe the
most important
moment i could have that day
it's small things so
let's not forget those small things
the the text messages and emails i got
are you okay
are you okay are you okay from all
across the country
and while in some ways it was
overwhelming
just the idea that people are reaching
out just the idea
that that nobody knows
really what to do with this but they
want to know
are you okay
and probably for the first time
over and over again in my responses i
used that
broken heart emoji
because it's heartbreaking
so healing takes place
every day and in terms of belonging
it has to do with recognizing each other
recognizing that we are human
beings every one of us
and some of the responses i've been
getting as i walk around town because i
walk a lot
here in boulder is
we're seeing each other and there's an
acknowledgement
and that's been happening throughout
covet
it happened to me uh during the
the the protests and the
horrific murders
uh that were happening to black and
brown
people in our country where all of a
sudden
i got noticed people that
maybe would just walk right by me
without seeing me stopped to acknowledge
my black body in their space
sometimes it takes tragedies
for us to look
up and see each other
but it's always worth it
always always always
and i just want to share a short piece i
wrote
that i want to offer to our community
to all the families that are affected
directly and indirectly it's called
surely
there is a bridge surely there is the
bridge from here to there
it is built one segment at a time one
step at a time one experience one memory
one sharing and pain and loving
at a time a lifetime of
segments that builds the bridge of
relationship
of who we are and for each
other surely there is a bridge
from here to there it's a way we connect
remember and cherish those who have
touched
our lives and where in moments of grace
we could become more together
than apart more spirit
more love more force for good and the
beauty
of living
surely there is a bridge
from here to there
each step is but a mere
glide on the wings of god
a journey a voyage a home
coming a peace
thank you thank you norma
next we'll go to um two together adela
aguirre and jesus salazar both
um who assist us as community connectors
yeah thank you my statement will follow
in english
[Music]
familiar
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
before i begin i just want to give my
condolences to all the families and
friends that
have um special connections to the
victims
of this tragedy and thank you so much
for sharing those
words of the friends that of these
victims they
brought tears to my eyes and i just
really really recognize the
how special these people were um my name
is
i was born and raised here in boulder
this tragedy has impacted our community
like never before
most of us are conscious about the mass
shootings happening around the country
but never in my life did i think that
this would happen here in boulder
um even as i as a young kid growing up
here i
never second guessed my safety as a
community because as a community
connector i know that
my communities are very strong and
resilient
um and the next steps from here are not
to only heal
most importantly but also take action
so that other families and other
communities that come
across the country and even world
i'm never have to experience this pain
thank you thank you adela and jesus
um next we have lupita montoya
uh hi everybody jesus also has comments
oh i'm sorry i apologize sevilla jesus
please
not always thank you uh thank you all
for your time and help the people who
unfortunately
you know it's an interesting an
interesting time that we're living in
uh i know cells are both a resident for
15 years community connector worker
[Music]
and my team that sometimes thought of
water as boring
uh though as i get older i've had the
opportunity to visit other cities and
towns across
america and even
sorry
that you turn off your camera because
your sound
is a little stable and that might help
you
thank you yes as i was saying uh though
as i get older and have had the
opportunity to visit other cities and
towns across america
and other towns the colorado my
appreciation and love for both girls and
financially
i grew up going to kings uber's both out
30th and table meso
for groceries to pass the time or to ran
a movie from the blockbusters inside
king soup race before the redbucks
it's chaos never when i walked into you
hear about the situations happened i
think such a horrific event what
happened in my town the recent change in
boulder has caused
significant
oops i'm sorry but it looks like we've
lost
adela and jesus um
if we get them back in i will come back
to jesus
um in the meantime
we will call on lupita montoya
thank you mayor weaver dear boulder
community
i'm just going to read my statements
because i already have done quite a bit
of crying
i want to make sure that i can get
through this
i'm speaking today as someone who lives
works
volunteers shops warships
and races her kids in the city of
boulder
the tragedy that at king zumber akin
supers
impacted me deeply as this is my
neighborhood grocery store
and i was really lucky not to be there
during this horrible incident
when i when i first heard about it
i had just left my youngest child at
fairview high
for the warm-up before a soccer game
against boulder high that afternoon
i usually go to king supers to shop
and then return to watch the game
on monday i decided to go home
instead of going shopping
to finish some work and then return to
the game
while at home my child called me to tell
me
what was happening at king superstar
and then i have to go and pick him up
and we come home and we stay home
since then i have felt numb
i have cried but now
i just simply want a better world
the first things that came to my mind
when i heard about an active shooter
akin supers was
i hope i hope there are no debts
and please god do not let it be
do not let the shooter be a young person
sadly it was again a young person
who perpetrated a horrible act we just
lived that
a week ago in atlanta
this is another young person who has
seen no other alternative
than to cause unspeakable pain to others
so my question is
what are we doing wrong as a society
to produce so many young people
who end up committing these sorts of
acts on a regular basis now in this
country
i feel deeply the loss of lives and i
have prayed for them
as i often pray for people who lose
the people that we lose regularly to gun
violence
into suicide i have a special
regard for people lost to suicide
a lot of young people are dying that way
it is my nature to seek understanding
and meaning in life
and i would like to think that this
horrible
act that happen in boulder is an
opportunity
for us to do better and to do better
than to get angry
or to be sad i want to ask
every member of our community especially
the adults
how is it that we are contributing to
the loss of hope
that the young people in this country
are experiencing
how can we change this terrible path
that we're on
where younger and younger people are
either
giving up on life or want to cause harm
to innocent others
i encourage the city council to continue
these talks
and lead us into action i see this work
on par with a much needed work
that we must do to achieve equity and
justice in our country thank you for
listening
thank you lupita next we have nikhil
mankikar
a community leader and two-time past
chair of the human relations commission
nikhil thank you sam uh boost i want to
thank uh
the mayor weaver and members of city
council who
are calling us together tonight and with
the invitation i appreciate it
uh i'm nikhil manches i'm a
uh older native born and raised
in this community this is my home
i want to start by giving thanks love
and prayers to officer vitaly and his
family
to all 10 victims who lost their lives
in this tragedy
i also want to give my thanks and love
and playlist to chief heald
boulder police department all of its
officers sheriff peli
the county sheriff's department fbi law
enforcement agencies
district attorney michael dougherty and
everyone in the boulder county da's
office
for the incredible response this week uh
to such horrific incidents and
uh and the continued response and
follow-up going forward
uh this this wound and the pain of it
uh is is just immense
and especially for those of us who who
who've grown up in boulder and called us
home
have lived really a long time um
it's just it's a lot and uh
i'm just thinking of how just days
before
uh this tragedy happened i was uh
driving my dad
uh right by that king supers in table
mesa
and we were in the neighborhood and uh
we're taking a drive and talking and he
uh he just exclaimed 50 euros to me and
i was thinking
i'm not close to 50 yet what are you
talking about and he said
50 years since i came to boulder
and he came to boulder 50 years ago and
made this his home
and all the families home and we're just
talking
reflecting on that and uh beautiful
bolded community
uh and by beautiful we were not just
talking about
the mountains and the trails he took us
on hiking his kids
uh but uh other beautiful people in in
in
boulder that all the friends we call it
friends and family
uh as there's the tragedy hit
on on monday i think of his uh his best
friend who also came here in the 70s who
lives
right by that king zoos and walks in
that neighborhood and into that king
supers every day
um i think of how uh i used to go to
school
i used to go to lunch uh doing after
school every day at that king supers
and uh i'm just glad it was spring break
i can only imagine all the young high
school students who would have been
when this tragedy happened otherwise um
looking back i remember columbine
uh and all the memories associated with
that
uh and and the change how it changed
people's sense of
feeling unsafe just unsafe doing
something you do every day going to
school
um and how that stayed with us since and
i just had instantly recalled you know
having metal detectors installed
at the high school up there and how it
changed all their lives
not only as students but as we grow up
um
and then i think of people being afraid
and uncomfortable to go see a movie with
friends after the
loyal theater tragedy in 2012
and the list goes on and now this
uh as the events of days ago unfolded i
i
thought of all of this i thought of as i
watched the events unfold on the news i
thought of
you know friends uh people i've worked
with
childhood friends and in the boulder
police department
you know messaging them contacting them
to see if they were safe
friends who live nearby and table mesa
and us
calling each other to check if we safe
um
my mom's oldest friend going back to
college lives in atlanta and they were
just
talking about the tragedy and the hate
crimes in atlanta
only that she was facing in her own
community only days before
and she was shocked to turn on the news
and see this in boulder
um and the many friends from outside
boulder and outside the state who've
messaged and connected that day and in
these days since that have followed
uh to show they feel the pain and
showing they care about us
and our community we do this
because we genuinely genuinely
solve it we do this because we genuinely
care for each other as friends
as human beings and as a community
and to me that's the path forward
for now there's no easy answers and
there's no easy fix for this
the wounds and pain of what our bolder
community is going through
is something we will be going through
for a long time to come
no doubt about it but that connection
that we have to each other
that is the path forward
our strength and resiliency as a border
community
doesn't just come from laws politicians
or political bodies
clearly it comes from each and every one
of us everyday people who make up
make up the city it is and the community
it is that we call home
so please be kind to each other
be gentle with each other to take time
for one another
careful with each other that's what we
can do right now
and that's what we have to do always so
love that enables it
and may peace be upon us thank you for
the opportunity to speak
thank you nikhil next we have john tayer
president and ceo of the boulder chamber
of commerce i want to give
john in the chamber a shout out for
having lit the boulder star um
as soon as the tragedy struck so john
well let's start by thanking the city
also for the partnership
in the lighting the boulder star um
and i'll say that you know there's been
so many profound
statements um of grief tonight uh so
well
articulatedly stated words of comfort
um and there are commitments to healing
and building back stronger
i can't begin to try to match that
and i won't um but i just will say that
the boulder chamber welcomes all of
those sentiments
as a testament to the unity and strength
and resilience of our community
um you mentioned the boulders star
mayor weaver and those are the very
sentiments that we hope that the boulder
lighting of the boulder star reflects
and we
intend to have that uh lit through the
next
uh 10 preceding days in honor of the 10
victims that we that we lost
um so that will be lit through monday um
but there's something else that we want
to convey and it oftentimes gets lost
in the reflection on such a terrible act
of violence
and and that is to thank you um
we want to first thank um as
the boulder chamber and the boulder
business community uh those first
responders
who many have acknowledged tonight
but it comes right front and center to
all of us
how they put their lives on the line on
every day
and we see that in fact
terribly it can come to
a death of a law enforced a heroic law
enforcement officer
like officer talley and we thank
our law our first responders every day
for their protection
we also